الى الشان اليمني الان حيث قال رئيس وفد
جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين لمفاوضات تبادل
الاسرى باليمن عبد القادر المرتضى انه جرى
الاتفاق في سويسرا على صفقه تبادل واسعه
تشمل
7.6 من الحوثيين في مقابل 181 اسيرا من
الطرف الحكومي بينهم سعوديون وسودانيون
واضف المرتضى في تغريده ان الصفقه ستنفذ
بعد ثلاثه اسابيع كما ستعقد جوله اخرى بعد
شهر رمضان المبارك استكمال تنفيذ بقيه
الاتفاق
من جانبه الوفد الحكومي ماجد فضائل ان
الصفقه ستشمل 880 اسيرا ومقتطفا في مرحله
اولى تتبعها مراحل اخرى وصولا الى الافراج
عن كل الاسرى على اساس قاعده الكل مقابل
الكل واضف في تغريده على تويتر ان الصفقه
تشمل اربعه صحفيين محكوم عليهم بالاعدام
وقاده عسكريين ومدنيين وعددا من اسرى
التحالف
معنى الان من امام مقر الامم المتحده في
جنيف مراسل الجزيره ايمن الزبير كيف هي
الانطباعات حول هذه الصفقه ايمن وانت
تحدثنا من امام
المكان او المقر الذي تجرى به هذه الصفقه
لماذا تنفيذها بعد ثلاثه اسابيع من اليوم
نعم قبل قليل انتهت الندوه الصحفيه التي
عقدتها الاطراف بحضور المبعوث الخاص الى
اليمن هانس جروندر بيرج الذي اكد عدد
الاسرى الذين سيتم اطلاق سراحهم وهو
706 من جماعه انصار الله الحوسي والبخيه
من الطرف الحكومي انصحها التعبير بخصوص
تنفيذ هذه
الاتفاقيه سالنا لماذا هذا التاخر علما ان
الطلب كان هو ان يتم تنفيذ هذه الاتفاقيه
في اول ايام رمضان الاطراف ردت بان هذا
التاخير يعود الى اسباب لوجستيه وضروره
التعرف على الاسرى كان يتوقع قبل انطلاق
هذه المفاوضات ان يتم احياء ما يعرف
باتفاقيات عمان التي كان بموجبها سيسم
باطلاق ما يناهز
200 اسير ولكن هذا العدد او هذا الطلب لم
يتحقق وفق المشاركين لعده اسباب اهمها
ضروره تحديث كشوفات الاسرى هناك بعض
الاسماء غير موجوده ولكن جماعه الحوثي
قالت قبل قليل ايضا انه لم يتم الوصول الى
هذا الاتفاق لانها كانت تتفاوض مع اطراف
عده على حد تعبيرها من جانبها او من جانبه
الطرف الحكومي يتحدث عن تعنس وعن مفاوضات
عسيره لكن يقول ان الوصول الى هذا الاتفاق
وهو جزء بسيط من اتفاق شامل يعتبر انجاز
في حد ذاته وان الفتره المقبله بعد رمضان
ستشهد جوله اخرى للوصول الى صفقه الكل
مقابل الكل وبالتالي قد تصل الاطراف الى
هذا العدد وهو ازيد من 22 وبالتالي قد
نكون امام جولات اخرى بعد رمضان الان
المطالب الاساسيه لمنظمه الصليب الاحمر
وايضا للهيئه هيئه الامم المتحده هي
التنفيذ العاجل لهذا الاتفاق واسعاد
الاسرى واسرهم
معنا من جناز